so please welcome our first speaker
talking about
nature
and how it will work
within our cities
she is an archaeologist and professor at
ucla
take it away monica l smith
today we might be focused on the long
now
but what about the long ago
what are the archaeological
paleontological
and geological sources of the dust to
which we will all return
or perhaps we're focused on the
anthropocene because it makes humans
sound so important to have a geologic
era named after us
or maybe we're focused on the
intersection
between nature
and culture
the things that we surround with a
linearity
the ways that we bound nature to our
will in ways that say
watch out
something important is happening here
for humans
i'm an archaeologist and people are
always asking me where does the dirt
come from
why are archaeologists always
digging
and i ask them in return
why are you always
sweeping
because an archaeological site begins
when the last
person
puts down their broom
and walks away
and those spaces in our built
environment
are the places where nature
reinserts itself
subtly in the interstices
where new geologic layers can come from
anything
from pollen
from dust
from bird droppings
even
flowers
and these places in the interstices that
you might not have noticed
until just now
are places that i started photographing
a few years ago when i started thinking
about where archaeological sites
come from
most sites do not disappear overnight
like pompeii
they disappear in increments of dust
like a rook
or jericho
or mohenjodaro
or maybe they disappear in the tendrils
of vegetation that subtly overwhelm the
built environment
places like tikal
or angkor
or yasha
and in those linearities of human
intention
where the plants grow
there are many more species of plants
than there are species
of human
and that archaeology is what becomes
incrementally
in the spaces that we thought we had
designed for ourselves
but where nature and the plants
were waiting to take over
it might appear
as though nature conforms itself to the
spaces
where we allow it
but don't be fooled
it's just
waiting to put in
some spaces
those unruly places
the little spots
where the dust and the dirt
and the plant seeds
come in
it is as though nature is taking the
opportunity
to contrast itself
with the linearity that we offer in our
built environment
just
waiting
to implant itself
in the places that we thought we
controlled
like a dandelion
masquerading as intentionality
these are not
derelict places
some of these images are from the most
expensive zip code in america
some of them are just a few feet away
from one of the busiest intersections in
the country
and these places where we think we have
controlled
places where we put in
a classification
of space
of places that are curated
or planted
or free
are places where nature itself is just
biding its time
to come back to that sinuous
intersection
is it distressing or comforting to know
how the anthropocene
ends
in every contest
large or small
nature
always
wins
thank you
i certainly see it winning all over san
francisco on a daily basis
where do you see it in l.a
everywhere under foot now that you've
seen it you'll see it everywhere in the
steps in the cracks of the sidewalks
even in the traces of the freeway i see
now little bits of vegetation along the
medians and the margins even though
there are thousands of wheels passing an
hour nature is still
there
thank you for that meditation
it was great to have you here monica